hey guys it's awesome momvi and i play
vish
on hulu's original series this way up
you can check it out now
it's a comedy it's a drama it's about
moving on finding happiness finding love
sibling relationships it's also about
the adventures of a one foot tall
cloth doll that looks like me you'll see
what i mean when you watch it
anyway check out what else is on hulu
this month
we're all just out here trying aren't we
and sometimes what you want to do
is scream i really worry about you
getting carried away
shown up cop on carried away
i don't think i've ever heard so many
jesus yeah sorry to talk about my axe in
bed
[Music]
what do you remember about this we were
writing songs that were memorable
because we had to remember them
i want to read to you one little thing
paul is one of the most innovative bass
players that ever played bass
and half of the stuff that's going on
now is directly ripped off from his
beatle period
he's a great great musician did i write
that that is john lennon that's john
yeah
i hadn't heard that that's beautiful
[Music]
things star short for star breath
assuming yours is barbara nope
just barb plain old barb
we've spent our whole life trying to
unite the world
and i'm tired dude ted we have a destiny
to fulfill
greetings my excellent friends
[Music]
freddie concerning your private life
what more do you need to know
i make music fortune favors the bold
[Applause]
i need a research assistant she's one of
the best investigators i have
i want you to help me catch a killer of
women
if you want to get off this island do
not miss that trip home
the first people to set foot on that
island since it's forced
shut down what happened here again
dozens of unexplained disappearances
and the locals swear by the existence of
the half-faced girl
ladies and gentlemen michael jordan
look who's finally ready to play
perhaps i could be of some assistance
[Music]
i'm 21 i'm on summer vacation and i'm in
love
again can i get an olay olay baby
it's a race to gather the clues and bake
the mystery dessert
welcome to crime scene kitchen
[Music]
okay okay
join me peyton manning and my brother
cooper for our new amazing show
colleges go head to head in trivia we
got this
they're all fighting for our top prize
life-changing scholarships
peyton we're gonna go with must-see tv i
like it i'm gonna remember that
camera you've been hunting witches for
centuries
we need every soldier every weapon
for what's coming
[Music]
you